now we over fractions have we moved on
from fractions fractions we learnt
they've all the way back in you seven
with decimals and percentages and my
response to aren't we over fractions is
we will never ever be over fractions and
up don't panic I will put back these
questions in a second so if you haven't
written them all down
don't worry but I just thought I would
start thinking in my brain about all of
the subsequent places that you continue
to use fractions throughout the advance
and extension one courses and this was
the list that came up with now this list
is not for you to write down this this
is not even entirely for you to
completely understand because this is
about topics and I'm skills that you are
not going to learn for several months
but I'm just putting them there to point
out to you how enduringly important
fractions are these first few things
you're like oh yeah I think I we looked
at indices before right and you know
that when you introduce fractional
powers that's when you get square roots
and cube roots and all that kind of
thing but we continue going through and
we continue going back to fractions over
and over again trigonometry you might
have forgotten you might think oh that's
that's triangles right we're going to
keep on going away from triangles you
might think okay this is less than less
to do with triangles but what doesn't go
away thank you what doesn't go away is
that these are all based on ratios like
opposite on adjacent or hypotenuse etc
this is where they begin trigonometry is
fractions at the bottom and so as we go
into further cool things like graph even
like identities whatever those are our
ability to manipulate fractions becomes
even more and more important we've used
words like calculus and maybe said
things like differentiation before which
you don't you don't know about just yet
until a couple of terms time but when
you start learning these things
fractions come back and they become
again and again more and more important
so you want to be really comfortable
with these I'm gonna bring this back
later on but like I said it was just a
fun exercise for me to think okay we're
gonna keep on using these for the next
little while here a lot like almost
every topic there's a central way in
which factors matter okay now if you
have not written all of these it doesn't
matter cuz we're gonna start from the
top once I get my mile marker up
so each of these I think to be honest I
could set you all off to have a go out
on your own and in fact I'd love you to
start with the first one right now but
as we do it I want to highlight each
time the particular skill that is handy
that's useful when you attack these
problems okay
can you how's your viewing angle from
there instead okay so Brian uh yeah all
right so when we have a look at this
first one
oh yeah 3x I'm 10 plus 11x on 50 now
we've mentioned this before but it
serves reMed shitty what we're trying to
do to get these two fractions
interacting is get a common denominator
very good now abnormal way for getting
common areas when we started dealing
with fractions was you just multiply the
denominators by each other right so for
example 10 times 15 150 that would be a
common denominator between these two and
that would be okay
but in this case there's a better way to
do it what else could we do is that
straight okay I'm gonna go friend of
like 30 now why 30 let's work out what
it is
over 30 each night and then I'm gonna
ask all of you why 30 is a better choice
in this case what 1 multiply top and
bottom by to get to 30 yes you already
thinking ahead it's gonna be 3 so I get
9x
on 30 and then for the second one I will
not like followed by three and three I
multiply by 2 on 2 which gives me 20 2x
on 30 okay now just before we can buy
these instead of one fraction now I'll
ask that question to you why is 30 a
better choice okay number one it's just
smaller than 150 we I like my brain to
work with smaller numbers rather than
bigger ones do you have a different
suggestion yeah aha very good by the end
we want to simplify we want to get down
to the smallest don't know matters and
do braids we can so being that this is
some where we're going to end we might
as well not like go further away then
come back now a big question for you and
think back there's like a three-letter
acronym which you learn all the way back
in Year seven that relates these two
numbers to this one that gets you
straight to tell you what's what is it
it's a common snack yes the lowest
common
multiple right the LCM fellow is called
multiple of 10 or 15 is 30 right 3 lots
of 10 - lots of 15 so that's what we're
searching for okay with 10 and 15 it was
relatively easy but if I gave you orchid
numbers right you would want to do a
factorization of these which will come
later in very important ok so now we've
got this together 9 + 22 31 that's how
many X's over 30 am I finished yeah no
yeah so I mean this this number up here
is bigger than this one but it's yeah
it's C it seems like if I were to write
this out in like a split apart way we'll
be more complicated not less I'm I'm
pretty happy with it where that is
you're out with that content okay having
your like a question - now you can see
we go into algebra land here on the
denominator so we've got what's that is
that - v right v on X X minus 2 and X X
plus 2 right okay now when you have a
look at this guy to find the lowest
common multiple you're now thinking we
have to think algebraically here you
could think numerically you're like I'm
comfortable enough with these numbers
but here you can't avoid like you can't
think of what the number will be so yes
no suggestion yep keep going okay so
there's a word here that might be
jumping into your brain which is cross
multiply okay now I'm going to do
something that looks a lot like cross
multiplication but let me tell you right
now it's not cross multiplication let's
do it first and then I'll explain why it
is and I'll come back to this color
right we're gonna multiply this fraction
by what would I multiply by on the top
of the bottom that would arrive to my
common denominator in this case X plus 2
right so that's the thing that's missing
over here it says nothing in here that's
an X plus 2 so I need to bring an X plus
2 over so that's what I'm going to do
there's the X plus 2 on the top and then
on the double
denominator this is what I end up with
okay so I've multiplied here in here
over here I'm gonna multiply by
something different what's missing over
here on this denominator X minus T very
good so there's a plus and lo and behold
denominators match now it does look a
little bit like you've sort of
multiplied that way and you volta five
that way it looks a little bit like
cross multiplication the difference is
cross multiplication is what you might
do if you had something like this okay
now cross multiplication is really
short-haired for doing two things at the
same time if you multiply both sides by
X plus 1 and X plus 1 will appear over
here will disappear over there
so it's like it sort of moves over in a
cross form right like that same deal
with the X if you multiply both side by
X it's as though this X disappears and
reappears up here okay the difference
between this and this is what kind of
objects are these do they both start
with a we've looked at this right at the
beginning two weeks here
this guy's an equation there's an equal
sign right it starts off with an equal
sign what's this this is an expression I
introduced excuse me I introduced the
equal sign to help me simplify but it's
not equal to anything right so that's
why I cross what line doesn't actually
work in that case but now that I have
gotten a common denominator what will I
do just like before right I've got this
guy up the top five lots of this which I
think some of you suggest that I expand
which I'm happy for you to go ahead and
do and then on the die I've got that
chords a Taurus right okay so that's a
really great question that's a really
great question I'm going to throw this
to all of you in fact right on the
denominator you have observed there's an
X minus 2 and X plus 2 and that's the
factorization for the difference of
squares what would it be if you wrote it
just as one thing x squared minus 4 it's
this squared
take away this bit okay I'm going to
throw out to all of you who think
it would be simpler to write this as x
squared minus four heads-up no one
really I see a few hands three four five
people
okay peers now who thinks it's simpler
left in this X minus two x plus two full
okay and about another three or four
heads and then there's like ten of you
who are like I don't know I don't know
your hands up if you don't know you're
like I don't know it's it's one of the
are and then we've got a whole lot of
non-committal people okay so this is
really interesting all right put your
pens now because this is an important
thing I don't know how you would write
words on this or notes on this but I
just want to it's very important okay
for all these questions we're
simplifying okay but simplify the words
simplify it's a really dicey looking
word it's a really dicey looking word
because its meaning is entirely
dependent on context let me say that
again the many of simplify is entirely
dependent on what context you're in
right sometimes having something
factorized is the simplest way to write
it okay for example let's go back to you
what we're looking at with quadratics
right if I showed you this I would hope
that instinctively the first thing you
do is is factorize because that that
thing the factorized form it's easier to
work with but for what reason why is it
easier to work with that yeah I'm trying
to find the answer to the equation what
values could X take and I don't know
about you but I don't look at this and
immediately think oh if I put negative
two in there that should become zero but
when I look at this it's really obvious
to me I'm like a cool happy so in this
case factorization is better but I'm
gonna just go back up here when we learn
some of these later things for example
this this weird-lookin skill right which
we keep talking about this thing here if
for example once you learn what it is I
wanted to do that to one of these right
it turns out that this is actually
superior it's much easier for your brain
to handle it in that form in fact if you
had to do it with this you have to call
on some really difficult convoluted
rules which are completely unnecessary
okay so what I'm trying to say here is
which one is simpler and the answer is
it depends I know some of you were kind
of like I hate how mrs. Lee's mr. Wu
never give us a straight answer and
that's because you are now sort of
getting far enough into maths that there
aren't straight answers to most of the
things that you have to work with you
can't have to work that out yourself
so in this context well they're kind of
isn't like what do I do next
I don't know what I'm doing next in
which case they're kind of the same
right like do do you want your eggs all
mixed up or separate it into egg to
whites and yolks it's like I don't know
what I'm doing next so either of them is
fine okay
beam it either is fine I'm gonna do less
work rather and more so I'm just gonna
leave the denominator as it is are you
okay with that if I don't think it asked
to do something that makes it obviously
simple I'm gonna leave it but I can't do
something to the numerator hopefully
you've expanded and collected like tears
by now or if you haven't you can do it
now when you expand your gonna get 5x
Plus 10 I'm gonna collect like those in
a second 5x plus 10 plus 2x minus 4 we
know to be careful for those minus signs
how many X's will I land with seven of
them and what will the constant term the
number be plus 6 and I'm gonna leave
this guy here now there is one last
thing to check now that I've gotten the
top and it's all nice and neat does it
in any way the numerator cancel with the
denominator in any way are there any
common factors there
ya know I think it probably looks ok as
it is right I mean I suppose you could
like break this apart to get something
up but then that makes things more
complicated not let's we're done okay
but you should always check that to see
if there's anything that can kids or out